speaking of reputation there's someone
that has a reputation of writing some
really good books starting very young
that's right our next guest wrote her
first best-selling novel in college
that's right College her name is Chloe
gong and she's the author of young adult
hits these violent Delights and its
sequel our violent ends now she's
releasing her newest Thriller foul lady
Fortune it's a spin-off of her other
books and centers around spies in
Shanghai in the 1930s during the
pandemic Don connected with tens of
thousands of readers on Tick Tock
earning a massive following for her work
Tick Tock isn't Just For Dance videos
okay it's also for recommending books
and this one is definitely worth your
time foul lady Fortune is published by
an imprint of Simon Schuster which like
cbs's division of the Paramount Global
family welcome Chloe how are you doing
I'm good how are you good so not as good
as you Club yeah exactly I don't have a
best-selling no one two three
best-selling books about it this one is
already going to go yeah
Bravo so why did you decide to write
about Shanghai in the 1930s well my
parents are from Shanghai and they're
very proud of it my entire family they
love Shanghai in the same way that New
Yorkers love being from New York they
will always bring it up in conversation
they're obsessed with the history and
that's why people from Harvard do too
exactly working in a conversation yes
but go ahead yeah that's exactly my
parents yeah at any point if they're
seeing other like Chinese immigrants
they're like yeah we're from Shanghai
so your family history kind of
influenced absolutely this book yeah so
you know at the dinner table if they
were telling stories about the kinds of
things that you know their else was
talking about Shanghai the 1930s the
glimmer and the like all the glitz right
everything I was raceless you grew up in
Australia right that's New Zealand in
New Zealand that's why we we detect the
accent yes but it's very important for
you you say to bring the Asian culture
in the Forefront to your stories because
most people don't write about them
absolutely yeah I mean the Asian
diaspora is so wide like all these
stories there are so much to be told and
if we don't get the chance to tell them
it's almost as if Asian stories are like
a monolith and there's so much to be
told I just you know I'm so happy that I
get to be telling these stories of
course you started writing at the age of
13. uh what got you started honestly I
was really bored yeah I would go to the
library and I would finish reading all
the giant stack of books I got within
like three days and my mom would be like
we just went to the library I cannot
take you again so I thought okay I'll
write my own but at 13 you were writing
about 18 year olds I was why why not
other 13 year olds you know as a 13 year
old I was like 18 year olds or so
worldly they're so mature I'm gonna
write about these people who know what
they're doing with their lives and then
I reach 18 and I'm like huh yeah that
was not right now you know less than
when you were 13. uh parents are always
looking at kids on Tick Tock and
thinking put that down and read a book
and yet here you are using Tick Tock to
recommend books absolutely yeah I mean
book talk is a huge part of tick tock
now like the community is amazing
everyone has such good book
recommendations and it gets people
picking up books like going to the
libraries going to bookstores you know
every like Barnes Noble now has a book
talk section I love it you know you also
write it but your latest book is about
assassins where does that come from
Chloe what do you know about assassins
you know I joke that I'm a violent
person I don't know where that comes
from sometimes I just you sound so
violent right right yes I just I love
describing blood go visceral things just
as a writer it really it helps me get
that description going when I'm like
okay I can see the splatter of red so
you know assassins I just think it's
really cool and it draws from Real
History right like in the 30s so much
politics was going on yeah but your
success has come so young at a young age
for you and some people like how could
she write this way at such a young age
and maybe Tick Tock has made it easier
for her than other writers who have been
more established than yourself what do
you say to that do people question your
your age well you know I get it all the
time they're like what do they say they
say you're only successful because
you're young you only got published if
you're young and you know of course like
being young has its benefits where I
have a lot of time to work on my writing
I completely acknowledge that but at the
end of the day you still need to write
the book yes someone has something to do
with it Chloe people still need to want
to read the thing and they do yes and
never apologize for your success yeah
you put the work in and you deserve it
thank you um how do you decide your
approach when it comes to writing for
young readers versus adults
well I started writing for young readers
because I was so young when I started
out you know it was really all I knew I
could again when I was 13 I only told
stories up to being 18. right because I
was like I don't know what 20 year olds
talk about taxes I don't know anything
about taxes uh so we're in Texas either
way yeah those book checks are coming in
you know about taxes now I know about
taxes well Chloe gong thank you so much
we appreciate you stopping by all right
foul lady Fortune is out tomorrow no
Chloe says she now lives in New York
pretending to be a real adult yeah come
by and hang out with us anytime good to
have you here